americans might know better college
students do not know better there's a
new poll app
this is from nbc news generation labs
surveyed a thousand more than a thousand
sophomore college students
survey revealed
almost two-thirds of college democrats
would not room with a trump supporter
62 percent so they probably would not or
definitely would not room with someone
who supported trump in 2020.
what's the number for republicans less
than half of that
only 28 of college republicans say they
would refuse to rub with a dem someone
who voted for biden in 2020.
what's the reasoning here well here's
what the dem said they interviewed some
of the people who participated in the
survey democrat kid says quote i could
never live with someone who supported a
racist homophobic xenophobic and sexist
person i could possibly room with
somebody who is a republican but when it
comes down to it donald trump is not the
average republican candidate so this kid
is saying that same thing
that all of the
extremely closed-minded liberals who
want to seem open-minded because that's
one of the values that they pretend to
appreciate
what they say is look
i i'm open-minded i could be friends
with a republican just not a republican
who ever supports any winning candidate
but if you support
i don't know liz cheney or something
then okay then maybe
maybe if you're a liz cheney mitt romney
republican i'll still probably hate your
guts but
maybe i'll talk to you so they interview
the republican kid republican kid says
hold on i'm going to do my my sort of
nice moderate wants to sound kind of
acceptable college republican uh a
person's political views do not affect
whether or not i would have a friendship
or relationship with them many of my
friends have vastly different political
views that i do but i do not let that
affect our friendship
and i don't mean to make fun of this
hypothetical kid
because
that's the nicer thing to say that's the
more reasonable thing to say
of course
you should if you get assigned you're
got a democrat in your
dorm or whatever of course you should be
able to get along we're all americans
right well actually on college campuses
there are a ton of foreigners but matt
we're talking about people who voted in
2020
well i guess some foreigners probably
voted in 2020. but in any case let's say
for the sake of argument we're all
americans we should be able to get along
even people who voted for the other
party
on the surface this is crazy
on the surface here the republicans got
it right democrats got it wrong
however though it is crazy to refuse to
to room in college for a year or two
with someone who has different political
views
it is normal
to prefer to live with people who have a
similar general view of the world that
you do
that is normal
the lib here
is in a very crazy extreme backwards way
actually articulating a pretty
reasonable concept which is
which is unity is our strength that's
really what they're saying even though
the libs love to say diversity is our
strength no one actually believes that
unity is our strength
doesn't mean you can't include people of
different backgrounds
doesn't it's not a racial thing it's not
a sexual thing
it's not a whatever you know it's not a
i don't know geographic thing
but you do want to have you want to have
more in common
with the people that you spend your time
with
then less
of course you do
that's that's what makes a community is
things in common
so yeah actually the democrat here in a
kind of bizarro way is espousing a more
normal point of view
you want to
you don't want just total uniformity but
you want to share some basic premises
with people and and that can lead to a
much more fruitful conversation
if you get a bunch of people in the room
who don't share any basic premises at
all let's say you get a bunch of people
in the room and they don't even speak
the same language are you gonna have a
fruitful conversation
no
if you get a bunch of people in the room
who agree on basic stuff what life is
kind of what what the purpose of society
is kind of
uh
really basic aspects of human nature
you are much more likely to have a
fruitful conversation and learn from one
another
the democrats get that the democrats who
preach that we need all sorts of
diversity and nothing in common and no
standards whatsoever
they're they
in practice what they say is no you all
have to agree with us we need to have
some things held in common and
ironically that's a very conservative
point of view the conservatives used to
know that before the conservatives
bought the the bs from the dems hook
line and sicker sinker back in the 60s
when the democrats upended all the
standards and norms and traditions
there's actually something to learn here
the republicans have to be willing to
room with democrats because there are
only like seven republicans on any
college campus and the democrats have
the political advantage of being able to
ostracize and exclude people because
they are the vast majority 90 plus of
college campuses
but maybe we can learn something from
them maybe actually
we need to be a little more muscular
in setting standards and norms of
behavior and saying no we're not going
to allow your crazy bs to come in and
destroy our society speaking of
ostracism of conservatives on campus
there's a very nice piece published by
fire
the
foundation for individual rights in
education
and it was on this this hubbub that
occurred with little old me little old
me whom everybody loves at the
university of saint thomas
uh some months ago apparently i had been
invited to the university of saint
thomas i actually didn't even really
know very much about this invitation and
then the school
unbeknownst to me refused to let me come
speak
and the irony of it is that the
university of saint thomas is a catholic
school and they wouldn't let me come
speak because i hold catholic views on
the social issues
abortion transgenderism
sex all this kind of stuff because i
hold to catholic teaching they wouldn't
let me on campus because they wanted me
to hold to liberal teaching and so fire
the individual rights and education
group
as a headline university of st thomas
promises free speech yet practices
censorship by denying college
republicans request to host michael
knowles
first paragraph
the university of saint thomas
harmonizes free speech with its
religious mission laudably promising to
give its full blessing to students
expressive rights as part of its
catholic identity yet when the
university's college republicans chapter
sought to make good on the promise by
requesting to host political commentator
michael knowles st thomas rejected the
request because administrators didn't
like his views thereby betraying the
school's commitment to free speech by
violating the group's right to host
conservative speakers
in fires june 28 letter to st thomas we
explained how the university's viewpoint
based rejection of knowles
violates students expressive rights to
host sinful
satanic or even blasphemous speakers so
i want to put a pause there i'm i am
actually grateful to fire for defending
me
and yelling at saint thomas for
rejecting me
but uh
respectfully
that's not what happened
the the school's rejection of me
this coming to campus did not violate
students
rights to host sinful satanic or
blasphemous speakers thank you very much
uh no i gosh with a defense like this
who needs opponents
and i see what they're trying to say
fire is trying to say you have a right
to say anything you want on campus but
one no you don't and
that's a very extreme libertarian view
but it's not true you don't have a right
to say whatever you want on campus but
two
the content of my speech
is not sinful or satanic or blasphemous
it's the opposite actually
the school rejected me
because my speech was not sinful or
satanic or blasphemous the school
rejected me because my speech was the
opposite it was a christian speech
it was informed by
catholic principles and the catholic
school rejected me because the catholic
school has become sinful satanic and
blasphemous because they prefer
liberalism and leftism to
christianity
the
the conservatives have fallen into a big
big trap here okay
free speech absolutism i wrote a whole
book on this so i won't belabor the
point free speech absolutism is not a
conservative value
academic freedom is not a conservative
value
it never has been those were always
left-wing values the modern conservative
movement began with william f buckley jr
writing a book called god and man at
yale the superstitions of academic
freedom in that book he called academic
freedom a hoax
the catholic school has every right and
frankly obligation
to not allow certain ideas on campus to
tell teachers no you're not allowed to
teach
nonsense people go to a catholic school
to get a catholic education
all education has to have limits and has
to be somewhat coercive because you've
got to teach kids something
that's the point you go into college
theoretically ignorant and then you come
out and you're supposed to know certain
things and have a certain view of the
world and be educated which means
brought up now usually what happens is
the opposite kids go into college
knowing a lot of stuff and then they
leave more ignorant than they left and
this is actually even backed up by
certain social scientific surveys but
it's also backed up by common sense we
all know that that happens
so
no you can't teach everything you can't
have a school that teaches at the same
time two plus two equals four and two
plus two equals five you can at the same
time have a school teach that good stuff
is good and also the good stuff is evil
you can't
you can't have those two things you've
got to pick you've got to have limits
here
so i appreciate the defense from fire i
really do i i
i tactically i'm really glad they're
defending me
but the reasoning that they're using
here
is not not correct i'm glad you like
that clip now you know we hit a million
subscribers i'm so pleased i'm really
thrilled about the million subscribers i
get the nice gold play button it's very
very cool you've got to head on over
though and ring this bell and
get the notifications and subscribe
because i want to hit a billion
subscribers so do it now
thank you
see you next time
[Music]
[Music]
you